Hallöchen ihr Lieben! Willkommen zu einem neuen, leckeren Tortenrezept.
Und zwar habe ich mir überlegt ich mache heute eine No Bake Kinder Country Torte.
Ich kam auf die Idee weil ich gestern diese leckeren Kinder Country Donuts gemacht habe.
Kleiner Spoiler!
[Hamza] Warte mal, dein Gesicht ist so scharf - Jetzt!
[Kiki] Oh!
[Hamza] Du bist aber auch scharf Kiki! *lacht*
[Kiki] Iiih, Hamza!
[Kiki] Was für Sprüche! Auf jeden Fall - *lacht*
*beide lachen*
[Kiki] Ist so!
[Hamza] Wie in 'ner Bar: "Ey, du bist aber scharf!"
Also: Diese leckeren Donuts kommen bald auf dem Kaufland Kanal online, kleiner Spoiler!
Und ich kam auf die Idee weil ich hatte noch Funny Honey ohne Ende übrig!
[Kiki] Und deswegen dachte ich mir -
[Hamza] Das ist einfach nur Smacks im Endeffekt!
Ein Smacks Dupe! Wir machen jetzt einfach eine leckere Kinder Country Torte!
[Kiki] Läuft die Kamera?
[Hamza] Yes!
Sehr gut!
Ich mach jetzt nämlich schon direkt den Boden, der muss nämlich gleich ein bisschen auskühlen.
Und der besteht aus Vollmilchkuvertüre,
die habe ich in der Mikrowelle geschmolzen bei 600 Watt, nicht länger als 1min oder 80sek.
Passt bitte auf und rührt ständig damit ihr keine verbrannte Kuvertüre habt.
Da gebe ich jetzt noch zerlassene Butter rein.
Heute alles in der Mikrowelle geschmolzen.
Das geht auch überm Wasserbad falls ihr keine Mikrowelle habt.
Meine Eltern haben ja bis heute keine Mikrowelle, meine Mutter mag das nicht so.
So! Und dann rühre ich das und gebe das dann zu diesen Smacks Dupes
und verrühre das ordentlich.
So, der Boden ist soweit und jetzt brauchen wir einen Tortenring.
Ihr dürft auch eine Springform verwenden wenn ihr mögt.
Ich nehme jetzt den Tortenring weil ich den auf 24cm einstelle.
Hier ist mein Cake Board damit ich's auch gleich anheben kann.
Das Backpapier ist wichtig damit ihr den Boden nachher lösen könnt, sonst ärgert ihr euch.
Und hier ist mein Tortenring, 24cm.
Dadurch, dass es jetzt eine No Bake Torte ist, könnt ihr auch 23, 25, 26cm wählen.
Das ist nicht so wichtig.
Aber weicht nicht ganz so stark ab, sonst wird die Torte am Ende richtig hoch oder richtig flach.
Jetzt habe ich das alles schön verteilt und das kommt jetzt in den Kühlschrank weil das muss alles fest werden.
Und je nachdem, wie kalt euer Kühlschrank eingestellt ist, dauert das so ungefähr eine ¾h.
Vielleicht auch nur ½h, mein Kühlschrank ist immer sehr kalt eingestellt.
Und wir machen in der Zwischenzeit aber schon die Creme, okay? Bis gleich!
[Hamza] Okay!
[Kiki] Das ist so cringe wenn ich so rauslaufe!
[Hamza] Wo willst du hin, wie willst du - Mach doch Treppen runterlaufen, Keller!
Ja, Tschüss! Bis gleich, ne Uwe?
[Hamza] Das ist cringe!
[Kiki] *lacht* Okay, das ist echt cringe!
So, für die Creme habe ich hier ganz viele Zutaten, die ich euch in die Infobox genauestens aufschreiben werde.
Aber als kleine Übersicht: Ich mache eine Mascarpone-Sahne Creme
mit Schmand, mit Zucker, mit Vanilleextrakt
und wenn ihr mögt mit etwas Magermilchpulver.
Das ist nicht Kaffeeweißer.
Da hattet ihr mich unter meinem XXL Kinder Pingui Rezept gefragt, ob's Kaffeeweißer ist.
Das ist nicht dasselbe aber wenn ihr kein Magermilchpulver habt, dann lasst es einfach ersatzlos weg.
Ich persönlich finde das gibt nochmal diesen gewissen Kinder Country Geschmack,
also zumindest das Innere davon und deshalb nehm ich's mit rein.
Ich gebe jetzt alles in meine Küchenmaschine, ihr könntet auch euer Handrührgerät verwenden.
Aber ich mache es so, dass ich alles reingebe bis auf Sahnefest
und lasse das dann erstmal langsam miteinander verrühren damit es sich verbindet.
Und dann werde ich immer schneller und schlage das ungefähr 1min.
Und die ganze Creme wird fertig wenn alles schön steif ist.
Also auch die Sahne wird darin richtig schön steif und dann ist sie fertig.
Und in der Zwischenzeit einfach Sahnefest einrieseln lassen.
Mascarpone, Schmand und Sahne sind schon drin - alles kalte Zutaten,
Zucker, dann habe ich hier mein Magermilchpulver und Vanilleextrakt.
Die Creme ist fertig, die schnellste Creme - wie oft sage ich das?
Die schnellste und leckerste Creme! Die ist halt sehr variabel.
Ihr könntet auch Quark z.B. nehmen aber ich hab's lieber ein bisschen fester damit's auch schön schnittfest ist.
Mein Boden ist jetzt auch fest geworden.
Und ich hab mir tatsächlich überlegt, ob ich nochmal ein paar.. äh.. wie heißen sie nochmal? Dupes? Smacks!
Ob ich ein paar Smacks in die Creme reingebe
aber die würden euch aufweichen nach 'nem Tag oder so oder nach 'nem halben Tag.
[Hamza] Dann schmecken die so labbrig!
[Kiki]Dann schmecken die so labbrig, das passt nicht!
Dafür haben wir sie ja schon auf dem Boden und ich gebe gleich für die Deko noch was obendrauf.
Also der Boden ist auf jeden Fall schön fest, ich kann ihn gut anheben.
Und jetzt nehme ich mir mein Cakeboard von unten drunter
und löse schonmal - damit ich's gleich einfach schöner transportieren kann auf meine Tortenplatte -
löse schonmal den Boden.
Super easy!
So, zack!
Und jetzt einfach die Creme on top geben und schön glatt verstreichen.
So, ich hab das jetzt schön verstrichen und so lange muss die Torte jetzt gar nicht kühlen
dadurch, dass wir eben 'ne feste Creme haben.
Aber ich hab grad schon gesagt: Ihr könntet die Creme natürlich auch mit einem Anteil an Quark machen.
Ich lese ja immer eure Kommentare und ganz oft wird halt die Frage gestellt:
"Was kann ich ersetzen in der Creme wenn ich dieses und jenes nicht hab?"
Ich werd euch das in die Infobox aufschreiben, das finde ich persönlich am Einfachsten.
Und die Torte gebe ich jetzt nur für 20-30min in den Kühlschrank
und zeige euch solange den Schoko Drip.
Drip! Den Schoko Drip!
Für den Drip ganz wichtig: Sahne erwärmen und nicht aufkochen.
Und sobald die Sahne dann warm genug ist, einfach gehackte Vollmilchkuvertüre reingeben
und solange verrühren, bis sich das zu einer homogenen Masse verbunden hat.
Das lasse ich dann nochmal 10-12min stehen damit der Drip einfach so ein bisschen dickflüssiger ist.
Und jetzt habe ich auch meine Torte aus dem Kühlschrank genommen
und nehme mir meinen Backformlöser damit ich mir die Seiten jetzt auch nicht wegreiße.
Einfach da entlangfahren, den Boden könnt ihr dann auch direkt mitlösen.
Dann nehme ich den Tortenring ab und werde den Drip mit einem Löffel verteilen.
Der Drip ist verteilt, on top sind natürlich noch ein paar Kinder Countries Pflicht
und ein paar ähm... Smacks Dupes! Warum sage ich das immer?
Und ein paar Cerealien! *lacht*
[Hamza] Also das ist keine Werbung für Kellog's, nicht für Kaufland oder für Kinder Country!
Nein, das ist einfach nur eine leckere Torte, die ihr unbedingt mal nachmachen solltet.
Ich schreibe euch wie gesagt alle ganz genauen Mengenangaben in die Videobeschreibung.
Wenn ihr dieses Video feiert und das Rezept generell, hinterlasst einen Daumen nach oben
und bleibt auf jeden Fall bis zum Schluss dran denn gleich wandern wir rüber ins Wohnzimmer zum Tasty Table.
Und dann bin ich super gespannt wie du die Torte findest!
Ich lasse den Drip aber noch aushärten, das dauert ungefähr 15-20min.
[Hamza] Ohhh!
[Kiki] Und dann schneiden wir an. Komm, so viel Geduld haben wir noch!
Okay, also bis gleich! Ah! Ich sag an der Stelle schonmal:
Tschüüss, eure Kiki!
[Hamza] Das darf jetzt nicht fehlen!
[Kiki] Nee, das ist Pflicht!
[Kiki] Und jetzt! Bei 3 bist du bereit und redest, ok?
[Hamza] M-hm!
[Kiki] 1,2,3!
[Kiki] *lacht*
[Hamza] Boah ich würd mal gerne sehen, wie das aussieht!
[Kiki] Boah, das sieht richtig cool aus!
[Hamza] Bestimmt richtig Anti!
[Hamza] Egal! Leute.. ich klatsch nochmal, ich hab das in der Hand.
[Hamza] Taste Test! So, wat geht ab hier?
[Hamza] Aber ich find das cool hier! Diese Deko ist richtig schön, so wie in echt, ne? Wie aufm Kinder Country!
[Kiki] Ja, wie aufm Feld!
[Hamza] So, mal gucken wie das schmeckt hier!
[Hamza] Wir haben jetzt eine Schokoschicht oben, Mascarpone..
[Kiki] Mascarpone, Schmand, Sahne, Vanilleextrakt und wieder Magermilchpulver!
[Hamza] Das erinnert mich irgendwie an Nippon ein bisschen! Kennst du Nippon?
[Kiki] Der Boden, ja!
[Hamza] Jetzt haben wir mit dem Boden auf jeden Fall so 'nen Crunch.
[Hamza] Die Sahne gibt die Frische und die Schokolade gibt die Süße.
[Hamza] Einfach geil!
[Kiki] Ohh! Echt? Du guckst mich voll verliebt an!
[Hamza] M-hm!
[Kiki] Liebst du mich? *lacht*
[Hamza] Also ich merk auch einen Unterschied zwischen diesem Magermilchpulver wenn's drin ist und wenn's nicht drin ist!
[Kiki] Ist echt so, ne?
[Hamza] Das schmeckt jetzt wie das XXL Kinder Pingui die Sahne.
[Hamza] Man merkt schon einen Unterschied beim Magermilchpulver!
[Hamza] Leute wenn ihr's nicht habt dann macht's ohne aber ich find's mit schon mega lecker eigentlich! Also..
[Hamza] Das harmoniert richtig geil! Das ist mal so ein anderer Kuchen, weißte?
[Hamza] Weil der Boden auch anders ist, der gibt richtig Crunch! So richtig Crunch!
[Kiki] Aber jetzt fragen bestimmt viele: "Ist der Boden nach dem Kühlen zu hart?"
[Hamza] Das ist jetzt kein weicher Boden, den man einfach so trennen kann.
[Hamza] Man muss schon ein bisschen mehr Druck ausüben aber das macht's voll aus!
[Hamza] Das macht's voll geil!
[Kiki] Also es ist eher knusprig und nicht hart!
[Hamza] M-hm. Also ich glaube wenn man den ein bisschen früher aus dem Kühlschrank nimmt und ein bisschen so länger stehen lässt..
[Hamza] ..bei Zimmertemperatur, dann ist es ein bisschen weicher.
[Hamza] Aber ist egal Kiki, lass den hart sein! Ich find das gar nicht so schlimm!
[Hamza] Jetzt darfst du reden! *lacht*
[Kiki] Ich hätt jetzt nur gesagt vielleicht ¼h vorher aus dem Kühlschrank nehmen, dann ist er wirklich perfekt.
[Kiki] Boah, das hört sich gut an! *lacht*
[Hamza] Leute, macht's unbedingt nach! Ich sag das zwar immer aber macht's echt nach..
[Hamza] ..weil das ist mal ein anderer Kuchen. Weil der Boden anders ist find ich.
[Hamza] Das ist so - das wird Kinder Country total gerecht!
[Hamza] Ich hab jetzt nicht damit gerechnet, ich dacht du machst jetzt einen ganz normalen Boden!
[Hamza] Und dann machst du Kinder Countries drauf und das ist es Kinder Country von der Sorte, weißte?
[Hamza] Aber das ist was ganz Neues, mega!
[Kiki] Dankeschön!
[Hamza] Ehrliche Worte von einem ehrlichen Mann!
[Kiki] *lacht* Du bist süß!
[Hamza] Würde ich nicht wissen, dass du das selber hier reingemacht hast, reingemixt hast..
[Hamza] ..würde ich denken das ist ein Nippon Boden.
[Hamza] Also seid ganz faul und macht einfach Nippon drunter!
[Hamza] Backblech!
[Kiki] Boah! Nee, ich glaub das würde zu süß und zu hart werden.
[Hamza] Ja, das kann auch sein.
[Hamza] Leute.. Kiki, hast du gemeistert!
[Hamza] Ich esse jetzt weiter und gönne mir noch ein Stück Kinder Country.
[Hamza] Peace and out. Mega. Mega!